um today we're going to talk about
machine learning with heterogeneous
graph so so far we have been talking
about machine learning with simple
graphs where there's no type information
inside the graph so nose and edges they
are treated equally they are homogeneous
So today we're going to cover a more
generic or more general family of scraps
where we can further consider the
category types of different noes and
edges and we call this a heterogeneous
graph so this will be the topic for
today's
lecture um and a quick announcement uh
we have the product proposal due today
so um so if you haven't finalize your
proposal it should be two page um uh uh
please uh finish today
um so let's get to the technical content
for today um today we'll be talking
about about heterogeneous graph so far
we have been handling graphs with only
one Edge or no type right so we uh just
introduce their are noes and edges in
the network without further describing
uh the types of these nodes and edges um
however um there are some very good
reasons that in reality uh the graphs
may come with types so how do we handle
this graphs where there could be
multiple types of node and multiple type
of edes and this is also known as
heterogeneous graph um specifically
we'll today cover three different
methods they can perform much learning
with heterogeneous graph um the focus
today will be the relational gcn uh
which is the first and the most widely
used method that can be used to learn
from hydrogenous graphs we'll then cover
a recent uh set of art method called
heterogeneous graph Transformer which
basically extend the idea we have
learned learn the graph attention
network from homogeneous graphs to
heterogeneous graphs and lastly we'll
start some discussions regarding how can
we Define a design space for
heterogeneous GN so if you remember a
few lectures back uh we have talked
about a general perspective for gns and
that was uh our homogeneous graph
without any type information so today
we're going to use some slides to
discuss how that frame work can be
extended to heterogeneous graphs as well
so the focus today will be the
relational
gcn so let's first motivate why do we
want to study heterogeneous graph why
this notion is even useful um earlier we
have shown that we want to study graph
because um it describe entities and
their relationships in practice these
entities uh or we call noes could have
different types let's say this is could
be like a citation Network among
different research papers and different
authors and for this graph we can
actually Define two types of different
noes so the red node could capture the
papers and the blue node can uh
represent the auers so you see because
we treat usually we will treat papers
and authors differently say we have some
paper specific attributes like uh the
number of pages the topic of the paper
and we can have some other attributes
for the alers like maybe the nationality
of the author the which school the
author belongs to uh because this
different nodes could have different
attributes it will be natural that we
can represent them as two as two
separate types and then we want to
represent such types in the
network another example is the case
where we have different types of edges
and this could be also useful in our uh
citation Network so the first type could
be uh one paper site another paper
another type of connection could be uh
one paper or like another paper so they
are
similar so um similarly because there
could be different types of connections
and interactions in the network we may
want to represent them with different
Edge
types and then we can make the case even
more complicated so given a network you
can both have different types of nodes
and different types of edges um so um
still ring our example we could have two
types of node in the cation networks the
papers and Alors and we can additionally
have two types of edges uh that are the
citation relationship and the similarity
relationship
so altogether both nodes and Edge types
can exist in the same network and you
can already see um this heterogenous
graph can go very complex so there are
tons of combinations of like how many
noes and how many Edge you can consider
um in this uh heterogeneous
graph so how do we uh uh efficiently
capture this complex uh type
relationship in the heterogeneous
so the keyy idea throughout this lecture
will be the concept of relation um so
inside the relation it will be a topo of
three elements we talk about the
starting node um The Edge and the end
node so let's say given this red node it
will connect is with this a blue node
through an edge this green Edge and we
can use this tle to succinctly cut
capture the complex Rel relationship or
interactions between a pair of node so
we capture the type of the starting node
we capture the type of the edge and then
the type of on the ending node so let's
make this U more concrete uh in this
example in total we could have um eight
different relation types because we talk
about there are two different Noe types
and two different Edge types and because
we are considering this Tapo and each
element of the Tapo you have two choices
so alog together you could have eight
different uh potential relation types
from uh paper side paper paper like
paper um up to an another side paper and
another like paper so overall there
could be eight different relation
types and in practice and uh in the
remaining of this lecture we will use
this relation type to describe an edge
so so um this is as opposed to we
directly use the edge type to direct uh
to represent an edge um the reason is
that as we can see this relation type is
more expressive and it can cover um the
better captures the interactions between
a pair of noes and
edges um any questions so
far um question I guess could an HP both
could two be similar but also each
other so you mean one Edge contain two
types yeah that's a good question um so
in our setting we cons we do not
consider this soal multi graph so one
Edge like a represent both types one way
to represent that information is that we
can add two different edges here so uh
let's say uh like one paper like another
paper and another paper site the same
paper also site the paper so we can use
two separate edges uh to represent it's
supposed two relations uh
exist okay so uh we will uh talk about
this relation type uh throughout this
lecture so with this uh definition we
can now like formally describe what is
really a heterogeneous graph um first a
disclaimer um there are multiple ways to
define a heterogeneous graph and you may
read different uh definitions either in
blogs or research papers but um all of
them serve the purpose of Des describing
a graph which has multiple note type and
multiple Edge types so we'll pick one
particular way to define heterog graph
um you'll have uh like a v r t and E
four components to describe a
heterogenous graph
uh first we have nodes with different
noes type so uh Wii is a particular node
uh inside a set of nodes and each node
will be described with a particular type
and to get get the type of given node uh
we have this uh transformation T that
basically tells us what is the type of a
given node
VI we then uh additionally Define the
relations within this heterogeneous
graph um and as we have motivated uh
instead of using a one single edge to
represent this relation we use a too
with three elements the starting node VI
The Edge e and the end node VJ and um
all out of all the possible relations
we'll use a set R to represent all the
relations um and finally um we Define
this Ed Type e uh that belongs to uh I
think a type we use the notation R here
this should really be
e um but basically we also Define an
edge type that belongs to a set of
different edges um overall this
definition all about is to say we have a
graph and we associate uh different
types for each node and different types
for each uh relation uh
topole um question sorry um a little bit
confusing about the notation so you said
relations with relations this specific
thats to R but then later you also the
Ed Type e also belongs in R yeah yeah
this should be a typo um uh I believe
this should be e so um so small e means
that a particular Ed type let's say site
or like and the capital e means uh the
set of all possible Ed types um I think
these are just tells us all the possible
toos inside the hogen yeah um I make
sure to correct after the
lecture so now we have defined
heterogeneous graph and you may wonder
that this notation seem to be pretty
complex and uh are there like a real
world use cases of using hydrogenous
graph and the answer is yes so actually
there are tons of real world graph that
should actually um be are represented as
heterogeneous graph um we will visit
several examples the first is a
so-called biomedical Knowledge Graph and
this can constantly arise in biomedical
applications um in this case you may see
there uh different noes with different
colors and that means that the nose
belongs to uh different types um for
example we can have um like a example no
this uh migraine um this is like a one
particular node and this belongs to the
red type of node which is a disease node
um and then we can define a particular
relationships uh between uh two uh blue
nodes which are the Dr Node um and then
there are other examples of node types
and H types so you see that in this
biomedical Knowledge Graph you can
Define uh different types of noes and
then capture their
relationships um another example is this
event graph um where um say an airport
airport SFO uh is one type of node we
can uh capture the relationship uh
between a specific flight that origin uh
from this airport um and in this case um
we can have a no type of flight and then
an edge type of
destination so in a lot of R scenarios
uh you can describe a graph uh together
with the type of the nose and
edges um question is there any way to
express the different level of closer
relationship for example in the biomic
knowledge gr there will be a a closer
relationship based on the micro which is
we cler relationship and then based on
the meta analysis which is the strong
relationship is there any way is level
relationship um so the question is that
can we uh represent those like a
hierarchical structure of the
relationships so in other words can we
even say build a um like the
connectivity between the relationships
yeah I I think that is doable although
we didn't talk about in this lecture um
so uh in that sense we are further
connecting we can further connecting the
edge types together so uh we can use a
separate construct a separate graph that
tells about the hierarchy of different
AR type let's say say um and that can be
used uh in a company with a different
heterogeneous graph but U with our
current representation we just assume
all the types they are like a treated
equally so we have maybe 10 not type and
10 Edge types but we can additionally
construct a graph that link different
not types together yeah yeah that's a
good
question um let's see more concrete real
examples of uh heterogeneous graph uh
another a very common use case is this
uh e-commerce graph um for example for
recommended systems uh we will have
different users different items and
different queries and they can be
represented as three different types of
noes um and then we will represent their
interactions as the edges but here the
ACT uh the edges can also take different
types so we can Define um the
relationship of search uh the uh
interaction type of click and guide so
there are also three and even more types
of interactions within this uh
e-commerce graph so um this is a very uh
widely used scenario in Industry uh when
people want to build like a um uh
recommended systems that can associate
different user item CES
together and uh one more example and
we'll also talk about a benchmark data
set from this example uh we can further
build an academic graph so including
different authors no uh menue noes and
field noes so there are three type of
fields and then we can also Define three
types of interactions um that is for
example announcer publish a paper a
paper belongs to a a field and there are
also citation um relationships between
between this different types of nodes so
uh this is yet another good example of
heterogeneous graph and based on this um
formulation of graph we will later talk
about a benchmark data set that is uh
the most widely used Benchmark for
hetrogeneous graph called a Microsoft
acadamic graph that basically construct
a this like a aler manual field like a
heterogenous graph over um all the Open
Access research papers and a lot of um
GM benchmarks are computed uh for that
Benchmark so now we have defined what is
a heterogeneous graph and seen a lot of
real world examples of heterogeneous
graph um before we jump into uh defining
like a machine model to learn from
hydrogenous graph uh I want to spend uh
two or three uh slides just to discuss
do we even need a hydrogenous graph so
like a indeed there are a lot of cases
you may find that there are type
informations associated with no and
edges but uh what we want want to argue
here is that um instead you can consider
model data type information as a feature
um alternatively so there are some like
a very like a important practical
decisions uh for you to consider before
you want to uh formulate your problem as
a hydrogenous graph so um our
observation here is
um instead of associate with node and Ed
with different types we can instead
consider them as different features so
one like a simple example is that we can
use an one hot indicator to uh represent
the types of nose and edges as an
additional features uh for example um
still using our example of uh academic
uh network uh for two types of no also
node and feature noes uh and paper notes
we can use a one H encoding one zero to
represent each aler node and a feature
01 to represent each paper note and even
though we may have any additional uh
like attributes for Alor and papers
suppose we append um this additional
indicator feature to this two type of
noes then essentially we have uh
injected this type information to the
network so uh in this case you no longer
need to directly represent uh the type
information but instead we can just use
them as additional
features um and similarly suppose we
have Edge types we can also treat Edge
types and as Edge features um and and
then consider learning from uh the edges
with additional Ed features um and and
this perspective we essentially reduce a
a heterogeneous graph into a standard or
so-called homogeneous Gra graph that we
have discussed um uh multiple lectures
um uh
before so are there cases when we really
need a heterogeneous
graph so uh here I show two examples
that I thought like are pretty like
important to use heterogenous graph but
you can consider more cases um the first
case that we have good reason to use
heterogenous graph in some cases when we
have a four dimensional feat
for alter notes um because there are
let's say four distinctive attributes of
a given alter and there could be a five
dimensional feature for paper node let's
say we have five different attribut for
the paper nodes so in this case um
suppose we just treat this type
information as features um you may find
an issue because now uh different nodes
have different dimensions um of input
features um and if you recall like for
any any graph in your network our
assumption is to reuse the message
computation across all the nodes and now
we face into an issue because right the
input feature for different noes are
different but we want to share the same
computational graph and that could be a
problem um of course like there are some
work around let's say we can map the
feature into the same Dimension but
still like um there are cases where um
the input feature Dimension Mis mismatch
um and in that case we want to consider
modeling these two nodes two types of
noes uh as a type rather than
features um in another example we may
have like a prior knowledge or external
knowledge saying that um these uh
different relation types should
represent different types of interaction
um let's say we have like a a graph
built over different languages um and um
the TPO the relation type um between
English translated into French and
another relation type English translated
to Chinese um these are two different
relation types and um suppose we want to
build a model to capture these two types
of interactions then this will require
different models so suppose we just uh
treat this information as feature
information then um we still we will
reuse or share the same weights across
all the edges um and that is kind of a
not uh what we expect and in this
particular case uh it would be better
that we model this information as a type
as opposed to as a feature so these are
just some um brainstorming ideas showing
that um what you should consider when
you decide whether a feature or
attribute should be considered as a type
or consider as a
feature um so uh here's like the the
final conclusion we have after the
discussions um ultimately we know this
heterogeneous graph is definitely a more
expressive way represent the
interactions between entities um uh
because it can capture different types
of interactions between the nose and
edges um however this also come with
costs um so for heterogenous graph it
will be more expensive in term of thec
computation because now we have
different types of interactions and it's
also more expensive in
um either in terms of the fact that we
want to store additional type
information and also that we are most
likely wouldn't be able to store
everything into one single Matrix but
different separate Matrix for each type
of information so it's more expensive in
storage as well and additionally the
implementation as you can imagine for
hydrogenous graph it will be much more
complex so it definitely come with cost
so our discussion here uh is to share
some insight that there are many ways
that we can convert a heterogeneous
graph back to a standard graph that we
have discussed uh in the previous
lectures uh uh that is so-call the
homogeneous graph um but suppose uh you
do want to model this complex and
different types of interactions between
the network uh you should consider using
heterogeneous graph
instead okay so now we have motivated uh
the idea of hydrogenous graph next uh
we're going to introduce um the uh
machine learning model that can learn
from hyren graph and particularly we
will talk about our relational gcn um as
the first and most widly used method to
learn from hydrogenous
graphs so um as a recap um this is how
we Define uh so-call graph convolutional
networks for a homogeneous graph um we
compute the massage message for each
neighbors with a A transformation um W
and then we perform an aggregation
across all the messages normalized by
the degree of the input node so um it
still falls under the message and
agation function we talk about and this
is for one uh for for a homogeneous
graph um and uh in our discussion we'll
slightly extend uh like the definition
of the graph so uh instead of consider
an undirected graph we'll consider like
a directed graph um just for the better
illustration as you'll see later um and
then uh we can consider the uh simplest
case um where there's only one types of
relation in this directory graph um and
based on what we have defined for gcn um
like a our goal is to uh Define a
computational graph that can generate
the representation for a Target note
a so this will be the computational
graph for this U particular directed
graph so we will look at A's neighbor B
C and D and B will have one neighbor C
and C has neighbors uh F and E and D
does not have any uh additional
neighbors so this is like the
computational graph for a directed graph
like this so um it's really nothing
different from what we learned except
that now because we Define the input
graph as directed uh the message will
only be passed along the direction of
the edges uh so recall that earlier
since there are no direction of the
edges the message are essentially passed
bir directionally so now this is pass
directly and uh we do not have consider
any additional type information here
this is the standard graph we have seen
a lot of times before so in this case
all the Transformations are shared so
you can see that um they are colored
with the same color so um which means
that we share the operation for all the
noes so now let's consider um the case
of heterogeneous graphs um and in the
case of heterogeneous graph we could
have um different types of relation that
we have U motivated earlier um so in our
example we have three different type of
relations and uh the edges with the same
relations we color them with the same
color um and additionally this relation
type as we talk about is really about a
topo of starting node Edge and end node
uh and we want to simplify the not
notation so we just use a single
relation say R1 to represent this full
typle of
relationships so this is our setting so
we want to um given this heterogeneous
graph we want to learn from it still
using this uh graph conval neuron
Network so what are our like a ideas
here um because we know that there are
different types of relations um our
intuition is that uh instead of sharing
the weights across all the noes now we
will have a a different weight Matrix
for each different types of relations um
for example we have this three types of
relations in this input heterogeneous
graph
um and based on what we have seen we
will then Define three different weight
matrices each weight matri is
corresponding to one particular um
relation type and we want to um like use
this different ways to um uh capture
this uh different interaction types of
interactions for a network so this is
our idea and motivation um of learning
from heterogeneous
graphs so what does it mean in the
computational graph is as follows so we
have the same uh computational graph
structure so right like a note a still
have B CD as neighbors um B has c as the
neighbors so the structure of the
competitional graph does not change at
all the only thing that has changed um
is the ways of the neural networks so
remember that earlier all the um neuron
networks or the ways are in the gray
color which means that they are shared
across all the nodes now because we know
there are different types of interaction
uh we will use different colors to
represent uh different types of
interactions um so let's uh see some
example um because we know the edge or
the the relation from node D to a um is
this blue R1 relation type um in this
computational graph we also make sure to
use this blue weight to represent this
particular relation type and for example
here uh A and C is uh transformed using
this red W and we can see that the Edge
from C to a is indeed um this uh red
type of edge R2 so this is um our uh um
basic idea of how to uh like a repurpose
a graph convolutional neuron Network for
Rus graph we keep all the computational
graph structure to be the same um except
that we will now assign different ways
for different types of uh noes uh
different types of relation
types um any
questions okay so this is essentially
the key idea of all the remaining
discussion in this lecture so we just
use different ways of or different
instantiations of neuron networks to
capture different relation
types um and we can Sy the same process
uh in a slight different will so um
instead of considering a heterogeneous
graph as one graph we can consider it as
n different graphs where like one
particular graph talks about the
connectivity uh with respect to one
relation type so because we can have n
different relation types we can consider
in different um graphs each connected
with one particular relation type um and
what we do is that um can be considered
as instead of learning from one giant
graph uh we perform Mach learning for n
uh different relational graph um each
for U each relation type and because we
know that there are in different graphs
we have defined in different set of ways
to uh represent um this different uh
types of input graph um question so this
kind of approach would make a lot a lot
of sense if we're sure that all the all
the this different labels for the edges
are truly independent right because
we're basically saying each one of them
is its own graph but I guess in reality
this is kind of like a choice for real
world data for us to make this kind of
choice that it makes sense to have four
different labels let say for edges is
there a way for me to analyze these
weight matrices so to know if there's
actually a co-variance between them or
not
so basically saying to help me choose
whether I should do hetrogeneous graphs
or not or how many in real world
applications yeah that a good question
um so I think the question is also
motivated by this observation in the
sense that uh we are curious like how
correlated are um what are the
correlation between each type of
relations um uh as far as I know I I
don't have like a uh knowledge about
like a very principal ways to detect
like a to what extent we should consider
as a homogeneous graph or heterogeneous
graph um but in practice like I would
suggest like you can try both method and
see which performs better um I think uh
usually um in practice I would suggest
you uh like a start with like a um
treating this type information features
as we had Mo earlier because it is um
much more easier to implement and
suppose the performance is not
satisfiable where you want to expand
higher performance then you can consider
using heterogeneous graph we haven't
talked about the implementation of heten
yet but usually it is slightly more
complex um than the homogeneous
graph okay so this is a another like a
perspective of what we are doing here so
we learn like a n different neuron
Network for n different subg graph that
are constructed from um the same um
input
graph so now we're going to talk about
the specific uh
like a definition for a relational gcn
and this is really like nothing
different from a standard uh gcn except
that we consider the type information
and we will use different weight
matrices to represent different
types um so this is the definition of
rgcn and you see that we still have a
lot of things we are familiar with right
so we uh use the weight Matrix uh W to
transform a given node uh will perform
an aggregation of over the neighbors of
a given not um and We additionally
perform an aggregation over different uh
relation Type R so we can still
understand this uh equation through the
two steps we have been talking about um
message competition and aggregation so
now um for a hetrogeneous graph the
message computation is uh specific to a
given Edge type
so um the you can see there um um a
subscript R says that um this weight
matrices is particular for one given
relation type um so we will transform um
the input node based on the relation
type we know um and then we can create
like a message based on um each of the
relation type um and it is worth noting
that we still consider like the ways uh
that transform the node itself so we
talk about we want to have two parts of
information right one part of
information from the neighbors of given
node another part from the node itself
so still we have this um term that uh
capture the transformation of the node
itself um and then after uh Computing
this uh different types of interactions
we'll perform aggregation um and you can
notice that U instead of performing a
one summation in the standard GC now in
this equation we have a double summation
this is because we first want to
aggregate the messages within one
relation type um as we have seen also in
the homogeneous graph but now because we
have um are different types of relations
we want to additionally summing over um
different relation types um so this is
like a how the AR is defined um over
different relation
types so uh next we're going to discuss
like what are the uh like the
implications and defin the um the
potential issues of this rgcn
formulation um so in the end we want to
learn the different weight Matrix for
each type of relations so ultimately we
have this R different weight matri
matrices and each which Matrix um has
the um complexity of d square which
basically says we have the uh input
dimension for each type of of the node
um given node type and then we want to
project it into the uh d l+ one uh to
the uh next Dimension um for the next
layer so this is like a the shape of a
given weight matrices and we want to
have R different weight
matrices and you can observe that um
because in inside like a hydrogenous
graph there can be tons of different
relation types so even there are say two
no types and two Edge types as we have
seen we can potentially have eight
different relation types so soon it will
become a overfeeding will become an
issue because you simply has defined so
many different uh weight matrices to
learn from um and this is an issue both
in term of over fitting and also from
the cost of the
computation so next um we're going to
discuss uh two practical methods that
are widely used uh to uh aleviate this
issue basically want to regularize the
wayte of w r l for each relation type to
make the cost to be more afford
affordable uh the first approach is to
use a block diagonal matrix to reduce
the number of parameter for each um uh
weight Matrix um for each uh relation
type the second method is to uh do a
basis decomposition or also known as the
dictionary learning to uh reduce the
effective number of parameters and in
practice you can actually combine both
methods to make the number of Weights
even
smaller so uh let's talk about the first
approach to uh track the computational
cost um so the inside is that we can
make this trainable weights to be sparse
so um and one option to make the sparse
is to uh formulate as a block diagonal
weight
Matrix um so earlier um we have always
assumed that any neuron Network
transformation are a fully connected
layer so in the sense that the weight
Matrix is a dense Matrix so all the
values are non z um and in this case we
want to reduce the number of parameters
by making it to be block diagonal so
only this block diagonal entries are non
zero the remaining entries are zero so
we can uh treat it as like special type
of sparse
Matrix um the limitation of this
approach suppose we want to use this
block diagonal matrix is that we will
only um consider the interactions
between the nearby neurons or the
dimension of the input so in this case
only uh suppose we are Computing over
the first block diagonal entries then
only the node one and node two they will
have interaction but the say the node
one sorry the dimension one and
dimensions three you won't wouldn't have
any interconnection because there are no
ways to represent this like a a remote
connectivity U but indeed this approach
is effective in reducing the number of
trainable parameters um so let's say we
use uh B to represent this uh low
dimensional Matrix um then essentially
by using this block diagonal idea we're
reducing the number parameters from um
uh d square roughly d square to um d
square uh over B so we essentially
reduce the number parameter by ratio of
b um another while use approach is to
share the weights across different Edge
types and essentially reducing the uh
tral parameters um in this case uh we
have the idea of so-called basis uh
decomposition or basis
transformation so uh instead of letting
this um weight Matrix WR to be fully
trainable we can instead U consider the
F formulation we have this um uh another
Matrix web to be like a so-called basis
Matrix uh and then we will train a
trainable Vector a RB that kind of um
tells us the importance of um the
weights of uh different uh Columns of
this Matrix VB so essentially what we
learn is only this ARB that uh tells us
like how to linearly combine combine
different Columns of the weight Matrix
web um and this way we can generate like
a different weight Matrix for different
relation type but without having to
Define our different uh weight
matrices so Ultima um to capture this uh
relational Wise information now we only
need to learn this Vector um a RB which
only has a b number of scalers so this
uh can also significant reduce the
number of
parameters so uh now we have to talk
about the idea of rgcn and how to make
the computation more tractable um next
we're going to discuss some concrete
applications how to apply this rgcn to
um say node classification and Link
prediction that we have also seen in
previous
lectures um so first for not
classification um uh the approach of
applying rgcn is quite similar to what
we have seen earlier so let's say we
want to predict node a which have K
different classes then um we still using
rgcn to generate the embedding for this
node a so we have this Vector for node a
h a l that represent um the final layer
of output for this node a and then we'll
compare our prediction with the the
ground and then uh perform the center
back propagation so this is very
standard we have seen this in
homogeneous graph as
well um what becomes more uh like a
compli complicated is for link
prediction so recall that for link
prediction uh itself is already complex
for homogeneous graph so it will be even
more complex for heterogeneous graph so
we talk about to perform link prediction
we really need to split a graph into
four categories of EDG edes there are
the message training message edges that
are used to compute the embedding during
training time we then have additional uh
training supervision edges that want to
generate objective for training we then
have a validation Edge and test Edge
that are used for validation and test
set as well so there are four categories
of edges for L prediction um and then in
this heterogeneous graph scenario we
then have like a for each relation type
we have these four category of edges so
you can see that um um there are like a
for each relation type we have four set
of edges and they are associated
together with their Edge
type question so do we always like
randomly into message Ed Ed it depends
on the prediction T itself yeah good
question yeah how to split um indeed in
most cases we assume it to be random
split but suppose you have some um like
a prior knowledge about how to split
edges you may want to do so for example
um uh let's say we have like a want to
examine the out out of distribution
generation uh capability for given model
then we may want to um manually select
some like out of distribution stles as
the like a uh test set or validation set
but in most cases we just random
bit
um question with the basis learning
approach it seems like you would really
need to have a lot of different types of
edges for that to make sense because
you're going to mean the basis needs to
be a certain SI it's not going to be
useful and I can't really think of real
world graphs that would have many many
different types of edges like that so I
was wondering if you could give an
example yeah yeah good point like a so
earlier we have some example of
heterogeneous graph um like in Ser like
only suppose we only have two not type
Edge types there are eight relation
types and suppose we have even like 10
not types and 10 Edge types then it
could be a thousand different relation
types so that's one way to understand
like there could be potenti lot of
ration types and another good example in
practice um is that like a suppose we
have um heterogeneous information across
different domains um and we still want
to use one giant graph to capture
everything we know so we talk about this
bomatic
um like a Knowledge Graph right there
are tons of different uh drugs and
different patients um different
molecules uh in that case you can easily
Define a lot of like a types of noes and
type of edges in this application even
in those
examples not every Edge type goes with
every node type right so it's not
doesn't really seem like it's actually
combinatorial the way that you described
it seems like it's really more like
linear in the number of types for a lot
of these yeah that is also fair I think
um as you as I also mentioned like some
of literature they do not consider this
relation type uh for the same reason you
have described because in a lot of real
world cases like it's not really
combinatorial the edge type already
clearly defined the relation type um but
still like uh first in some cases
there's it could still be combinatorial
and in other cases you can still Define
tens of different relation types so
these are some reasons we still want to
like a uh make the competition more
tractable
yeah yeah but great discussions um so we
talk about the formulation of Link
prediction for heterogeneous graph um
and let's see a concrete example um so
for example we want to uh predict this
Missing Link from node e to node a and
this is uh for particular Edge type uh
relation type
R3 so what we will do is that we want to
get the embeding for node e and node a
and then we'll uh use this like a
bilinear transformation to get um the
score for this um particular missing
Edge so we want to multiply this Vector
with the trainable weight Matrix and
then with a um another Vector ha to get
the prediction for this missing Edge so
this is one way to construct the uh link
prediction head for this um
heterogeneous
graph um and then we want to outline
this specific training and validation
steps uh suppose you want to perform
link prediction on hetrogeneous
graph um first um as we talk about we
can score all the potential supervision
edges in the network we talk about this
from E R3 to a is one particular Tapo
for um uh for the score and we can uh
use the same idea to score like all the
uh supervision edges in the network um
and the second step is to perform the
negative sampling so um we didn't uh
dive into details about netive samping
in link prediction earlier um it is good
time to discuss it now so um so when we
want to make link prediction besides
this So-Cal like a positive edges
because we know that there should be a
link between this par of node which
should also additionally consider
negative edges otherwise like the the
classification is like not well defined
right we should both have positive
examples and negative examples um when
we def Define a maing problem and how do
we generate this negative edges one
common way is to um make the corruption
of a like a gr TR positive Edge um what
I mean that for example we know there's
um like the uh ground truth connectivity
between uh e and B um we could uh uh
sorry E and A and then we can consider
craft the tail of this Tapo to uh swap a
with node b and d and you can see that
node B and E and uh d and e these two
edes are not existed in the network
right so um they they are not existing
Network so we treat them as negative
examples so we label this potential pair
of nodes as negative so this is the idea
of next sampling so given a positive
Edge that we know we want to corrupt it
uh to some non-existent non-existent
edges and then this way we can get both
positive examples and negative examples
and that can um finish the setup of Link
prediction and then um um we will also
use GM model to score this negative
edges and how do we train the model well
we will use the same standard binary
cross entropy loss that we have also
discussed earlier in the lecture um and
our motivation is that we want to
maximize the score of this training
supervision edges um that are positive
and then minimize the score of the
negative edges uh that like want to
minimize score for the negative edges
and this is kind of the last function we
want to optimize with uh question
yeah for the prev um so thees should not
to traines or edges yes what happens if
you have a really Den connected and that
like you can't do that because they're
all like no all
the yeah good point indeed this is like
a good like a hypothetical example
suppose the graph is already densely
connected um I think in that case
actually um the link prediction problem
is kind of e defined because if the
graph is already densely connected and
there's no possibility of adding
additional edges then um like basically
there's no way to infert additional
links because it's already fully
connected but it's like a good example
so in that case I think um uh it is it
is not very meaningful to Define link
prediction because graph is already
densely connected yeah but good question
um
question
I see so the question is how to
understand negative sampling and this
negative edges is this the question yeah
yeah so uh that's a good point so
actually um uh I I wouldn't think that
this two Notions are very correlated so
um here the idea of negative sampling um
the negative edges is just to manually
conr con struct some of the edges that
does not exist in the network um I think
for negative sampling is like a more
General strategy for training like a uh
like a binary classification task where
there are tons of like a netive examples
and we want to sample some and during
the training so how do we choose
this how do we choose that yeah so like
we said like we want to corrupt like
given the gr truth um uh like a positive
Edge you can grab one side of the edge
and this way you can get the Negative
Edge okay so we talk about having got
the positive and negative edes we can um
like can train the network to optimize
this loss or binary classification
loss um and then at evaluation time we
want to evaluate how how well the model
can rank the edges with different
relation types um so so for example now
we have a new Edge to to predict over
like a pointing from E to D with the Rel
time R3 so uh to make such prediction
our intuition is that the score of e r3d
should be higher than all the remaining
like a negative edges that are not in
the training uh message edges and
training supervision edges so this is
what we hope the model will be able to
see or to predict uh in this evaluation
stage so this is a specific metric that
we want to uh like a report uh let's say
in this validation time so first we'll
calculate the score of this Edge that we
want to make the prediction from e r Ser
to D and then we want to calculate the
score of all the negative edges um and
use the same method we have just talked
about so we want to correct one side of
the edges
and in this way we can get Negative
edges um so this way um we can get a
score for all the negative edges as well
and the third step is a most important
thing here that we want to obtain the
ranking of the positive Edge over all
the negative edges um so this way we
know that for example the model can rank
the positive Edge as the uh the second
among all the edges um and finally we
can uh report some ranking based Matrix
like um Heat at K which says that did we
correctly rank the POS Edge to be the
first uh Edge and this like a reciprocal
rank tells us like the reciprocal of the
rank as well so these are some uh
standard ranking metrics for this
problem um
question
slides uh just clarification question in
the last function right there that is
index
Su relations yeah yeah that's a great
Point um yeah I believe here we only
talk about one relation type and you are
right in the sense supposed want to
guide the final loss uh loss function we
need to sum over all relation type yeah
this is just for one particular relation
type yeah good
question so um so now we have talk about
how to evaluate like a a a link
prediction problem for hyrogen Craft um
so the the purpose of all of this
discussion is also helping you get like
a a goal over the idea of Link
prediction again um and we talk about
something we haven't mentioned earlier
about this ranking Matrix um and this is
just for your information of
understanding so it's not like the most
important part of this
lecture and next we're going going to
talk about specific Benchmark data set
as I motivated earlier that is why they
used um like a in the literature and you
could potentially considering your cross
product as well so this is called a
Microsoft academic graph uh it has like
over almost like a around the million of
uh paper notes and around million of
alter notes um there are also
institutions and fields of study noes so
now we see there are four different note
types in this particular
graph
um and then there are also four directed
relationships between this uh not types
um we have also affiliate with an
institution Au WR a paper and author
paper size a paper and paper has a topic
of field of study so there are four
different Edge
type um and the prediction task here is
to uh predict uh the value of a given
paper um uh the features of different
notes are actually generated from the uh
word wack feature Vector um so it's like
a standard approach for natural language
processing to get like easy to compute
encoding for um a given um uh sentence
or paragraph um and then given this uh
feature we have for different types of
notes we want to predict particularly
for uh the uh paper uh no type and
predicting the uh value of each paper um
and it is regarded as a
349 uh class classification because
there are um this number of Vues um
regarding data set split um I think
student as a great question how to split
data set um in this particular case we
do a Time based split so this is no
longer random split because um we have
this time stamp for all of these like a
occurrence of nose and edges so we want
to respect that time when we construct
the Ming task
so during training time we will select
all the papers published between uh 2018
as training uh all the things happen
after that uh the year will be regarded
as the test set so um this is kind of um
The Mach learning setup for this um
Microsoft academic
graph so we can see some um uh results
on this benchmarks you can actually uh
log into um the website of OGB open
graph Benchmark to see more
performance um you see that RGN can
generate reasonable prediction for this
task achieving about like a 47% accuracy
um and then the state of art method is
actually doing better um is doing about
like a 59% accuracy uh um and then the
method is actually a combination of uh
comp complex and simplified G GC will
actually cover both metrics in the uh
later offering in of of this course um
so the discussion here is just uh to
give you an intuition how people have
apply this rgcn into a practical machine
learning Benchmark and how this
Benchmark looks
like so to summarize we have talk about
the major uh technical component of this
lecture which is rgc um the idea is that
U we can um assign different weight
matrices for different types of
relations and this way I can extend gcn
to relational gcn and um this method is
pretty General we can uh apply this to
all the task we have seen for
homogeneous graph as well including node
classification and Link prediction and
this idea can be also extended to other
types of GN so we can apply this same
idea to extend to graph stage to G8 Etc
and with particular uh like I mentioned
the most widely used Benchmark for
hydrogenous graph um and how it can be
used in in
practice okay so now we have talk about
RG the uh the most easier to understand
and also why Ed method next we're going
to briefly talk about a recent uh St of
our method called hydrogenous graph
Transformer um like this is more for you
to understand the research uh in this
ction and see what are the interesting
ideas uh to build hydrogenous
GM so recall that we have introduce the
idea of graph attention networks um for
homogeneous graph um and what is new or
different uh from gcat to gcn is this
trainable attention weight so instead of
like a always normalizing based on the
Node degree we have like a trainable
attention weight computed from noing
Bing to uh light the model to weight
different neighbors so this is idea of G
and our question that g is designed for
homogeneous graph can we extended for
heterogeneous
graphs so um of course what we have seen
just now of ARG this idea rgcn can be
extended to R Gat as well so we
basically Define um n different like a
gat models each for one relation type
and uh we are done to extend the method
but this approach is actually very
expensive because um as you can recall
the competition for attention is already
very expensive so we have um um like a a
separate branches of computing attention
ways and then attention ways it usually
is So-Cal multi-ad tension so we have to
duplicate the wayist for n times or k
times and then suppose with additional
duplicate for each of the relation type
is simply too expensive so the question
that can we try to reduce uh the cost
for just um like a for hetrogeneous uh
graph
attention um another background that uh
we want to cover here is about like a
so-called uh scaled do product attention
and this is essentially the attention
mechanism that it used in the famous
Transformer architecture um so what we
do here is that to compute the attention
uh versus uh with respect to
uh query q key K and value V we want to
Define this um so called scale dot
product so we want to perform a DOT
product between the key and values and
then scale it with the uh square root of
the dimension and then use that to
weight the values V so this is kind of
rough idea of um scale do product um and
then how do we obtain this qk and the wi
right so we we don't don't have them In
The Raw input data so usually what
people do is to apply apply linear layer
to transform the same input to different
um uh different matrices qk V so we have
the same uh input x to the uh Network
and then we'll apply three different
types of linear layer or
transformation that can um project this
x either to Q to K or to V so this way
we can like a get the three like
component we need uh in this um like a
scaled uh um do product
attention so now uh let's uh like a
discuss how we can extend G8 um to
hetrogeneous graph um we can uh see this
uh we kind of rephrase what we have for
the G8 Network so we have the message
function compute from each of the
neighbors we have a tension score that
uh uh score like tells us like which
message is more important this attention
score is also computed by a neuron
Network and after scale the messages
will perform an aggregation to get the
final embeding so this is the idea of
standard
G um and our key question I want to
answer here is that how we how can we
make this attention to be specific to
relation type um the relation type as we
know have uh Topo of no type Edge type
and no type into this attention
computation so this is the key we want
to the key mod we want to Define for
hetrogeneous graph
Transformer so uh this is the idea
behind um the uh uh HGT hydogen hog
genous graph Transformer U we talk about
um the idea of projecting the input with
a A Q linear to the query and K linear
to the key so in this uh idea of Gat um
we want to decompose the too um and try
to project different components of this
um um relation type uh no type Ed type
no type this tple uh with different
projections and the purpose of doing so
is that we want to uh reduce the number
of weight matric we we can use here um
so in this particular example we have
alter no and paper notes um two types of
uh noes um and right and side so two
type of edges um we have three different
uh weight matrices that are used for uh
the cury paper uh key paper and key aler
three weight matrices and then we have
two Edge weight matrices uh one for the
side relationship and one for the right
relationship so alog together we have
five different weight matrices um so
suppose we do not have this
decomposition so suppose we do not break
down this relation type into a node Edge
and node type um is in Ser we could have
like a 3 by two uh * 2 * three 18 number
of different relation types uh because
we have have um this three no types two
Edge types and three no types um this
number of weight matrices so really uh
the idea of HGT is to decompose the
table and model like each component of
this node Edge node relation type
separately um and this way we can save
the number of weight Matrix uh we can
use
here um this is also like a glimpse of
the exact formulation of HDT um is also
not the main focus of this lecture but
just for you to understand what people
can do in practice um so we talk about
um this K linear and Q linear which
basically uh construct the key Matrix
and Q Matrix that we talk about in this
Transformer like attention network uh
and then after getting this uh q and K
we then perform this uh so-called scaled
dot product so we make a DOT product
between the uh query and the key but
because we also additionally have the
edge type between a pair of um nodes so
there's a third trainable ways for each
Edge type this a W for Edge Type e um
and this way we can get the attention
score that we have seen earlier also in
the standard trans uh uh Transformer
like
attention um so this is kind of the idea
of HGT in term of computing the uh
attention weight but then with respect
to the relation
type um and then a full H GT layer will
look like this so we talk about we have
the attention ways to waight different
uh messages and we have just computed
how to uh score um like a given message
based on the relation type we have just
seen this similarly we can U compute the
message with respect to different uh
relation type and uh here we also follow
the similar idea of decomposing the
weights for node and Edge types so to
compute a given message um we have the
ways for each node type so given a node
we will get is node type and then apply
a message transformation for this
particular node type um and then we will
multiply this node type um like messages
with a weight Matrix for U each Edge
type so you see that instead of we
model for this uh each particular
relation type so we have the number of
relation type of number of Weights we
now decompose into the ways for node
type and ways for Ed type so now we have
a summation of no number of no types and
number of edge types this number of
weight matrices so we reduce the number
of which matrices we want to use here um
there's a
question just a question about notation
can you explain what the symol circle
the
um you mean this one oh no I'm
sorry oh this one um yeah that's a good
question uh I assume this is should be
summation um um but I need to check
offline as well but um my understanding
this should be something similar to
summation because uh we have get the
weighted me message right so and we want
to uh sum over the neighbors of a given
note so is most likely to be a
summation question
isation
fun oh yeah yeah I think that exactly
what me so summation is just one option
this notation means any possible
aggregation function yeah yeah yeah
thanks for other question can you
explain why U just the attention uh
weights aren't enough to distinguish uh
like if the attention is different
weights for different pairs wouldn't
that be enough to capture like different
relation types yeah that's a great Point
um so I think the motiv this can be Ed
as the motivation of G right uh the
whole purpose of G that extend gcn is to
introduce like a trainable attention
ways for different messages but still we
have to compute the messages like um and
like for example we have Al not the
paper notes we want to construct
separate messag for each author and each
paper so we just uh additionally learn
like a attention way to score this
messages but still we want to
differentiate these two type of messages
so suppose we do not consider types for
like this messages then we kind of lose
uh a lot of information by sharing the
ways across types but a great question
yeah yeah
so um we have uh finished the discussion
of G uh
G HGT which is a widely used um like a
tension based me method for hydrogenous
graphs we can also take a look at how
HGT performs um on this Microsoft
academic graph data set u so very
interestingly we find that HDD HDT use
much fewer parameters and this is as
expected because now we have decomposed
the weight Matrix respect to each not
type and each Edge type so um it saves a
lot of parameter compare using rgcn like
it almost reduced by a number of
magnitude by an order of magnitude um
and the meantime it performs um better
than rgcn so um kind of this like a
illustration why HGT may be more
desirable in real world
applications so in the remaining of this
lecture I just want to briefly discuss
how we can extend what we have learned
from uh the design space of GN to this
heterogeneous graph scenarios so um
remember we talk about this five
components that outline the general
perspective of GN for homogeneous graph
and our question is that can we extend
this framework to hydrogenous graph as
well so um recall that the first
component we talk about is the message
computation um like um computer message
from each of the neighbors of a given
note um in the case of um heterogeneous
graph um we talk about this idea of
defining um like a one particular
message function for each uh relation
type so now the message function will
have a subscript of r that um represent
like a um one uh like a specific
function for each uh basically relation
type um and this discussion here is
useful because we talk about we can
model this measure function arbitrarily
so in rgc we talk about about just a
linear layer as the M message function
in practice this message function can
also be very complex can even be like a
two layer MLP or even more complex so we
can but we can still follow the same
idea so we Define a different message
function for different relation
type and then we talk about the
formulation of aggregation that
aggregate the messages of a given
no and in the language of um
heterogeneous graph now the aggregation
will Be A two stage process we also
briefly touch it in R gcn so here are
the two stages the first stage of
aggregation will aggregate the message
within each relation type because um for
example for a given relation type we may
have different members that belongs to
this relation type and having aggregated
over the relation type we may want to
additionally aggregate over all the
relation types um because now we have uh
information obtained from each relation
type and one particular example I would
recommend um to you can consider to use
is that in the first stage we can use
the sum aggregation over the members of
a given relation type we talk about sum
aggregation is the most Cally expressive
method um in this series of GN that
lecture so we can First Take summation
for uh each relation type and then we
can take a concatenation across uh the
relation type the purpose of using
concatenation is that now um we do not
have to consider the permutation
envirment property right because let's
say we have defined five different
relation type um they are clearly
defined so these five relation types are
explicit and we do not have to consider
the ordering here so concatenation is
kind of the most expressive way that we
can keep everything we have learned for
this five relation type so the second
agation could be the concat function
and we talk about the connectivities
between G and layers um including adding
the prepr layer post paring and Skip
connections and for um heterogeneous
genn we can basically keep the same
design uh for the homogeneous graph um
the only thing we can discuss is that
for those pre-process layer and post Pro
process layers we have this So-Cal MLP
layers and now this m MP layers should
be with respect to each node Type U the
reason is that the output of any GM
layer are no embeddings and because we
have potentially multiple node types we
want to separately transform the
embeddings of nodes that belongs to
different node types so now the MLP here
should also be uh type OS uh type
sensitive so this is like a how we can
extend this pre-process and post par
layers for a general uh
heterogeneous um and lastly we'll talk
about different ways of argumenting the
graphs um like we talk about how to add
a featur for notes and add a structural
information for heterogeneous graphs and
most of them are State and change um
except we want to discuss like two
common options when we want to
generalize the approach from homogeneous
graph to heterogeneous graph um so there
are basically two two ideas the first
idea is that we want to compute the
statistics within each relation type so
we talk about analogy of a heterogenous
graph can be regarded as n different
separate graphs so we can compute the
statices or perform the subgraph
sampling for each um of this like a
relation type and another approach is
basically we just ignore the relation
type so we uh treat the homogeneous uh
heterogeneous graph as a homogeneous
graph without any type information and
then we can UD the graph statistics or
perform sampling over the entire
network so finally regarding different
prediction types we have visited node
Edge and graph level predictions for
homogeneous graph and similarly for
heterogeneous graphs uh we just need to
consider this uh rediction Type R for
this different prediction
types and so now we have seen that we
can extend the idea of uh GN from
homogeneous graph to heterogeneous graph
and all we need is to properly consider
this node and relation type and have
some additional one layer of aggregation
over the relation type and that is all
we need to make such
extension um so to summarize today we
have talked about how to apply Gene to
heterogeneous graph and the key concept
uh you can take away is this a concept
relation type from the starting Noe Edge
and end node that describe all the
complex relationships in hydrogenous
graph and we talk about the idea of
learning from hydrogenous graph using
the same idea of GN we have seen earlier
and the key idea is that we want to
separately model each relation type with
GN and the most important part of this
lecture is relational gcn that extend
gcn to relational graph um and that's it
for
today